mein Gott mein Gott ich kann nichts auch
kein Doktortitel vor Obdachlosigkeit
retten und das ist es was ich den Leuten
zeigen will meine Liebe deshalb kämpfe
ich so hart
Los Angeles Downtown nur 12 km entfernt
von Hollywood von all den Reichen und
Schönen reich ist hier niemand aber
schön sollen sie sich alle fühlen das
ist die Mission von Shirley rains und
ihrer Organisation Beauty to the streets
drei bis vier Mal in der Woche kommt die
54-Jährige nach skittrow schenkt den
Bedürftigen warmes Essen einen neuen
Haarschnitt und Kleidung finanziert
durch Spenden vor allem ihrer Social
Media verloren
50 Häuserblocks etwa 10 Quadratkilometer
über 8000 Menschen wohnen hier die eins
gemeinsam haben sie leben alle auf der
Straße
eine Nachbarschaft von der es heißt auf
jeden Fall meiden niemals alleine
dorthin saugefährlich nur Penner und
Drogenjunkies und wäre Vorurteile findet
Shirley
die erste Frau die ich hier getroffen
habe hatte einen Doktortitel ich habe
mich um eine Krankenschwester gekümmert
die schizophren war ich habe mich um
einen Arzt gekümmert um mehrere Priester
ich will die Vorstellung davon was
Obdachlosigkeit ist ändern ich weiß
nicht warum die Leute denken sie kommen
hierher und finden diese dunkle
unterirdische Welt vor in der alle
undankbare Menschen drogenabhängige
Prostituierte Mörder und Vergewaltiger
sind
für Shirley sind sie keine Versager es
sind einfach Menschen die Hilfe brauchen
mehr muss sie nicht wissen
ich frage nicht nach Geschichten das ist
ihr Recht nur weil Menschen keine vier
Wände und eine Tür haben heißt das nicht
dass ihnen keine Privatsphäre zusteht
ich kenne niemandes Geschichte hier es
sei denn er will sie erzählen und die
meisten von ihnen wollen es nicht ich
kenne nicht mal ihren Namen ich nenne
sie Kings und Queens ich bin hier um zu
helfen daran ändert auch eine Geschichte
nichts
mindestens 500 Kings und Queens kommen
jeden Samstag hierher damit sie genug zu
essen bekommen steht David Mont Dragon
seit 5 Uhr morgens hier und rührt
kiloweise Bohnen
heute gibt es Pentagon Nudelsalat und
drei hähnchen-tacos die Bohnen rühren
und rühren wir damit sie schön heiß
werden ich komme immer so drei Stunden
vorher einfach um sicher zu gehen dass
alles gut ist
David ist eigentlich Broker war mal gut
im Geschäft bis Corona kam er verlor den
Job sein Leben geriet aus den Fugen dann
traf er Shirley und sie gab ihn wieder
eine Aufgabe er weiß wie schnell man
hier abstürzen kann
deswegen nur weil es uns besser geht
heißt es nicht dass wir sie so behandeln
müssen als ob es uns besser ginge wir
sind alle gleich wir alle sterben und
leben warum kannst du dir also nicht
fünf Minuten Zeit nehmen um jemandem zu
helfen
46 % der Amerikaner das sind 140
Millionen Menschen leben in Familien
deren Einkommen nicht ausreicht um ihre
Grundbedürfnisse zu decken Kalifornien
hat die höchste Quote mit
55%. die steigenden Preise Inflation
mietexplosionen verschärfen das Problem
in Los Angel liegt die
Durchschnittsmiete für eine Familie
mittlerweile bei etwa 4.600 Dollar und
was tut die Stadt definitiv nicht genug
sagt Charlie
die Stadt Los Angeles hat noch nie ein
Gespräch mit uns gesucht keine einzige
Maske gespendet noch nie gefragt ob wir
während der Pandemie Hand
Desinfektionsmittel brauchen ich werde
sicher nicht Däumchen drehen und darauf
warten dass die Stadt etwas tut ich weiß
was ich zu tun habe ich weiß was ich
seit sieben Jahren tue Frage eine Mutter
mit einfachem Schulabschluss die kein
Geld auf der Bank hat hat es geschafft
sieben Jahre lang Menschen zu ernähren
und das mitten auf der Straße wenn ich
das kann frage ich mich was diese
gebildeten Männer die tonnenweise Geld
verdienen und in ihren schicken Büros
sitzen mit ihrer Zeit anstellen
Shirley will ihre Kings und Queens nicht
warten lassen viele von ihnen stehen
schon seit Stunden hier an die ersten 30
in der Schlange bekommen ein Ticket
damit sich niemand vordrängeln kann
und dann geht es los möglichst geregelt
zuerst die warme Mahlzeit und Snacks
dann Kleidung anschließend Kosmetik
besonders begehrt Haarpflege sowie bei
chocolate das ist ihr Spitzname auf
diesen Moment hat sie lange gewartet
schön Dich kennenzulernen schön Dich
kennenzulernen wie geht es dir heute
sehr gut
hierherzukommen ich liebe Shirley ich
schätze sie so sehr denn sie kümmert
sich um die Menschen Gott segne sie mit
guten Dingen dafür dass Sie immer noch
skip
nach dem Haarewaschen geht es weiter zu
Sissi sie fährt jede Woche zwei Stunden
hierher um zu helfen selbst jetzt bei
extrem hohen Benzinpreisen
sie verdienen genau dasselbe wie alle
anderen auch also gebe ich Ihnen jedes
Mal wenn ich hier bin das beste was ich
habe sie verdienen es einfach
mit einer Engelsgeduld kümmert sich
Sissi um chocolates Haare und die
genießt es diese Pause von der harten
Realität
oh das ist eng
und doch weiß sie dass hier ist etwas
ganz besonderes
Shirley hat wirklich gute Leute wie in
einem richtigen Friseursalon
professionell und kostenlos
sind heißt das nicht dass sie keine
richtigen Menschen sind es bedeutet
nicht dass sie keine Arbeit haben oder
dass sie keine Kinder oder Familie haben
das bedeutet nur dass sie es sich nicht
leisten können so zu leben wie andere es
tun
hier soll es den Queens und Kings an
nichts fehlen dafür hat Shirley warmes
Wasser zum Haarewaschen besorgt
Haarfarben von schwarz bis blau Rasierer
für Bärte und Kurzhaarschnitte auch
James immer besetzt gerade ist ein
bekanntes Gesicht bei ihm
danach fühle ich mich immer besser er
macht seinen Job einfach perfekt wenn er
fertig ist sieht nicht nur sein Bad
wieder gut aus er fühlt sich auch
weniger wie ein Obdachloser und genau
darum geht es
sie wollen sich einfach wohlfühlen jeder
Mensch will sich wohlfühlen manchmal
duscht man macht sich die Haare nur um
auf der Couch zu sitzen man will sich
einfach gut fühlen und das ist etwas was
sie hier draußen einfach nicht haben
sich gut fühlen gibt pflegt aussehen wie
wichtig das den Menschen hier ist weiß
auch der Kota Nelson die 24-Jährige ist
für das Make-up zuständig
wir zeigen Ihnen was zu Ihnen passt und
sie suchen sich etwas aus Lippenstift in
einer bestimmten Farbe oder Nagellack
Wimperntusche oder eher keine ich bin
nur hier um diesen Menschen etwas
zurückzugeben
das meiste hier sind Markenprodukte
billiger Ramsch passt nicht zu Beauty to
the streets Dakota sucht für jeden
Geschmack und jede Hautfarbe das Beste
heraus
manchmal kommen sie sogar zurück und
sagen Sie mal dass es die Farbe die du
ausgesucht hast ich mag sie so sehr
dafür lohnt sich die ganze Arbeit
trotzdem kommt es in diesen Gegenden
auch immer wieder zu Konflikten Menschen
sind aggressiv gereizt manche von ihnen
stehen unter Drogen
Gonzales ist Security man und fast jede
Woche da um aufzupassen
das ist ganz normal ja das passiert die
ganze Zeit manchmal kommen die Leute von
allen Seiten ohne wirklich zu wissen was
hier los ist und sind sehr aggressiv
deshalb sind wir hier um sicherzustellen
dass nichts passiert
Konflikte gäbe es zwar überall aber der
Frust bei den Menschen hier nehme zu
erklärt Shirley ihren Hunderttausenden
verloren auf Instagram wie ihr
mitbekommen habt ging es in letzter Zeit
etwas aggressiver und turbulenter zu es
ist einfach die Wut die man gerade in
der ganzen Welt spürt hier in skitro
sind es etwa 8000 obdachlose Menschen
Tendenz steigend eingepfercht in 55
Blocks die Temperaturen liegen bei 38
Grad sie sind frustriert sie haben
Hunger sie sind verletzt sie fühlen sich
allein vernachlässigt
wer zu ihr kommt soll sich an die Regeln
halten sonst gibt's weder essen noch
Haarpflege stellt euch auf
Höflichkeiten erhofft sich die
alleinerziehende Mutter nicht sie
erwartet nicht einmal ein Danke
es gibt Menschen die sich bedanken es
gibt Menschen die sich nicht bedanken
und das hat nichts damit zu tun ob sie
auf der Straße leben danke ist nur ein
Wort es ist wichtiger was die Menschen
tun dass sie immer wiederkommen auch
wenn sie sich nicht bedanken wie oft
hast du nicht Danke gesagt wir alle sind
heute morgen aufgewacht hast du Danke
gesagt und Gott gedankt dass du am Leben
bist
nach zehn Stunden und 500 Besuchern und
Besucherinnen stehen immer noch Menschen
an Shirleys seit halb 2 Uhr morgens auf
den Beinen der Job ist hart
spendenakquirieren Einkaufen
ehrenamtliche finden vor Ort sein auf
Social Media zeigen was mit dem Geld
passiert klar
Shirley kommt den Bedarf kaum hinterher
es seien zu viele die Hilfe benötigen
und sie nicht bekommen ja gesagt ich bin
nicht die Richtige für diesen Job die
Stadt sollte das machen nicht ich glaube
Gott will dass ich das mache und warum
weil ich es kann und weil ich es werde
denn eines würde ich niemals tun ich
gebe nie einen Menschen auf ich habe
mich selbst nicht aufgegeben und ich
werde die Leute hier nicht aufgeben ich
glaube er hat mich nicht wegen meines
Wissens oder meiner Talente ausgewählt
oder weil ich ein guter Mensch bin ich
glaube er hat mich ausgewählt weil ich
einen Drive habe wie kein anderer
ohne entsprechende Politik wird das
Problem Obdachlosigkeit hier nicht
gelöst werden können und doch wann
shirley's Queens und Kings niemals auf
sie verzichten denn sie bringt das was
gegen denn wie Skidrow schon lange
verloren haben Schönheit mitten auf die
Straße
[Musik]